so you came into NBC they were doing
lousy right Different Strokes and Hello
Larry that was the comedy lineup okay
that's pretty bad really bad so who so
you go out and you find um well let's
think about it Seinfeld Seinfeld you got
Cheers Cheers uh cheers I was the low
man on the totem pole but at the end of
the first season yeah the lowest rated
show in the in all of the network
competition at the bottom of the Heap is
Cheers Cheers right yeah okay cheers
yeah but we renewed it because we liked
it we believed in it it changed the DNA
of NBC cheers was a huge hit the guy
they wanted to the network wanted to
hire to play Sam alone it says in your
book Fred Dryer was Fred Dryer Hunter
yeah yeah and and Fred Dryer hadn't done
Hunter yet that's the show you gave him
instead of cheers and but you said I
don't want Fred Dryer because he's too
old no no I actually thought Fred Dryer
gave a great audition right here's the
key we listened to Jimmy Burrows and the
Charles Brothers Jim Burrows is a genius
right he's a genius He Said Fred Dryer
is not good for the part he knew he said
I got what I got out of Fred it was a
long tough process now we're going to do
a series we're going to do 24 episodes a
year and you better be good Ted Danson
was your pick Ted Danson was the Charles
brothers and Jimmy Burrow's pick and no
one really knew Ted dancon no no no he
was an unknown hey we made Stars isn't
it amazing how sometimes we listen we
listened right to the executive
producers we thought the upside for Fred
Dryer probably was the biggest upside
wow and impressive but we listened to
the people we got in business with some
people were pushing for William devain
to be Sam Malone he also uh auditioned
it was a great audition but somehow Ted
and Shelly made it fresh it was young
and there there absolutely was a sparkle
Shelly long was the original girl in
cheers did she commit the ultimate
career suicide by leaving cheers she
thought she had a feature career and she
didn't did you tell her you don't have a
feature career did you sit her down and
try and talk sense to her you know I
didn't um uh basically she had a plan
she was very clear in her plan she when
Star but you have a star like that and
the the Network's making a fortune off
of Cheers don't you make some last ditch
attempt convince her that she's
committing career suicide um we did the
Charles brothers and Jimmy did right and
ultimately she had a plan and we moved
on was the greatest thing that ever
happened to the show chisty Ali comes in
yeah and we went more years with Kirsty
Ali than we had Shelley Long and it
changed what the show was and that's a
good thing and it changed it you say for
the better right it became bigger
absolutely I had nothing against Shelly
Long but you know what thank you Kirsty
Ali because she nailed
it